herzlich willkommen zu diesem video nach
einer langen zeit und ihr habt es schon
im titel gesehen ich muss mich heute zu
einer sache äußern
ich habe das handy von tim von gewitter
im kopf zerstört nicht nur äußern muss
sich auch äußert ich muss mich
rechtfertigen ich kann einfach nicht
mehr leben mit den anschuldigungen die
mich treffen außerdem werde ich mir ein
video zusammen mit dave der hier heute
im video dabei ist anschauen wo das
fernsehen zu besuch war genaugenommen
der wdr und darauf wollte ich reagiere
ich wollte das nicht einzeln machen und
jetzt habe ich diesen beiden kleinen
ideen die ich zusammen fügen wir dazu
diesem video wünsche euch viel spaß
freunde es geht um exakt dieses video
hier verstecken mit tourette in der
madeira villa ich war nämlich zusammen
mit dave re wie sebastian ganz vielen
anderen youtube vor kurzem auf madeira
zu der zeit in der sich auch der große
tanzverbot update skandale abgespielt
hat ich war auch auf der insel lebt
natürlich nichts mitbekommen weil ich
keine videos gemacht habe wobei ein die
hab ich gemacht das ist aber dass ich
sogar schon bekommen oder kommt jetzt
ganz weit auf jeden fall wir am letzten
tag verstecken gespielt zusammen mit
gewittern kommen und wir gucken mal
gemeinsam in das video rein ich sag mal
so viel ich war sehr überrascht als ich
geschaut hab das noch gar nicht gesehen
deshalb dabei weil er erstens auch mal
lehrer dabei war und zweitens weil er
hier seine authentische erste reaktion
zeigen kann auch das grauenvolle
geschehen ist
doch dicker ich bin hier fast unterging
so krank zu sein das ist das szenario
ihr seht mich hier auf der rechten seite
links neben zwischen uns revier und
hinten kommen noch tobi und tim von
gewitter im kopf seine sehr ausgelassene
stimmung würde ich sagen wohin es auch
an seinem gesichtsausdruck und der
genetik und nie hinten am fahrrad liegt
es ist einfach cool so wer uns gefreut
und video für rhede aufzunehmen des
videos auf super meist gewonnen ich
gucke es nicht ganz einig vor links und
stephan rein sagt dass er das war doch
jetzt genau hinsehen ich konnte nicht
damit so ich hole
[Applaus]
yeah
[Musik]
ich hab ihm das handy aus der hand
geschlagen alle haben dort gesagt und
auch themen jan alle haben gesagt das
war revisor und jetzt hört mal ganz
genau hin dass mir gerade zum ersten mal
aufgefallen
genau hinhören wer war das was du das
revier so war ich das und er soll ja
leute motto ich habe das video gesehen
ich dachte so althoff packt und dann
gucke ich in die kommentare
guckt euch mal an der ich habe an diesem
kommentar gelesen ich dachte sowas geht
jetzt ab wenn ihr der einzigste der
gecheckt hat das und revue das handy
kaputt gemacht hat sondern tragen
crafter und wer sich noch meldet als der
typ sagt hände hoch findet das revier
das bezahlen wo er in loser lügner haben
noch nicht weiter geschaut weil es kommt
jetzt noch das sind ja sonst landauer
wenn ihr findet das ist etwas bezahlen
muss das ist die szene und gerät leute
genauso klar ist was nicht im video ist
meinte er auch dass der basiswert war
das sonne und hab dann auch gesagt
sicher dass ich das nicht wahr ich habe
nämlich so meinen arm ausgestreckt und
hab halt jemand berühren am main ist so
soweit ich das habe ich das gemacht
weshalb nicht im video drin aber in
diesem video
weil alle sagen dir wie war s regel was
und ich dir so an der seite so soweit
folge schaut man dass dieses handy
kaputt ist von all diesen tagen dass ich
das mal dass ich es verschleiern wollte
job hier wie er dann noch so erschrocken
schaut und dann so eklig grinst angie
ich habe die kommentare gelesen und ich
dachte mir so hoffte fakten und dazu
kommt ich dachte mir wirklich so
das ist jetzt richtig also ich hier
reden story schauen wir das video der
hat recht ich zahle gar nicht ich hier
im stream zu sehen wir ganz genau wie
max gnadenlos das handy runter shepard
der fall ist ganz klar gibt es gibt eine
saftige anzeige lieber mag ich muss das
klarstellen ich wusste das nicht ich
habe gesagt war ich dass alle haben
gesagt privat und deshalb habe ich nicht
weiter drüber nachgedacht ich hab mich
schon längst mit ihm in verbindung
gesetzt
komme ich dafür auch und bezieht seine
versicherung aber das möchte nur kurz
darstelle weil niemals würde ich das tun
und das irgendwie unter dem tisch kern
glaube das wissen auch alle leute die
mich kennen revieren auch gesagt dass er
mir das gar nicht vorstellen will und
jakub gerber wirklich dass auch tim hat
ja in dieser situation wirklich gedacht
das ist randy war also es hat
offensichtlich niemand gecheckt so
richtig wer es war und wie es halt ab
gegangen da und deswegen waren
logisch ist der erste logische gedanke
das training genau team hat mir auch
geschrieben dass er gar nicht denkt dass
ich das irgendwie vertuschen wollte oder
so deshalb alles liebe arbeiten wir auch
anderes keine haben auf jeden fall eine
menge platz in dem haus und ich glaube
gerade mit gewitter im kopf stecken
spiel billigste und das sagt mir nämlich
auch ich dachte so never ever kann es zu
verstecken und gemeinden auch so jan
kannst du das überhaupt machen da meinte
er hat sogar schon mal einmal verstecken
spiel video gewonnen
ich hoffe dass wir unsere nation hier zu
bekommen
seit dem antritt von max um sebastian
brandt kraft und sp sind dann noch mehr
dinge kaputt gegangen anscheinend noch
mehr dinge als sie selbst wusste aber
ich wusste selbst nicht habe nämlich so
eine vase kaputt gemacht ich war so dumm
warum eigentlich und zwar so langweilig
dann habe ich einfach so eine vase und
lupe genommen so in dem früher geworfen
und das war um geschwommen wird und wer
das glück hat der so ab und knallt auf
den boden aber es war feinstes
entertainment ich würde es wieder so
weit weg von airbnb bekommen irgendwie
dass er noch nie wieder etwas suchen
will hat er hatte richtig angst dann
wenn nicht mehr guten 17 hier unter
einer decke das war so geil ich hab mein
versteckten gefahren ist so ist halt
wirklich kraft was würde ich natürlich
gefunden aber ihr seht ist hier an der
seite dann ist irgendwie so ein vorhang
quasi der unters bett geht und dann
runter wandelt decke unter die ich mich
gelegt hast notgeil normal
wirklich selbst in der küche verstecke
aber damals achten ich geb dir jetzt
heute chance bis leicht ist ja unfassbar
sympathisch beide jungen ich mag ja auch
richtig geld
das papier noch vielleicht getan mit dem
handy aber ich bin ja fast unterging
das war echt krass ihr müsst euch
vorstellen dieses dach auf dem dayton
sebastian sich versteckt
das war safety hoch achten die acht
meter 80 meter also nichts wo man sich
irgendwie an der kante und verstecken
wollte es ist zum zweiten mal jan
gefunden hier ist mir jetzt schon direkt
klar den berg immer war es ist halt ein
sehr gutes versteck das kann man nicht
anders sagen aber er ist natürlich klar
seht ihr das er macht das auf und dann
liegt einfach nur eine decke ich dachte
wow hat auch ein bisschen gebraucht um
zu checken dafür wirklich so vielleicht
geht er jetzt wieder weg und dann
hintergrund niemand befindet so what the
[ __ ] ist dass jemand hallo
das war okay das war auf jeden fall das
versteck video wenn ihr mich das ganze
video anschauen wollte ist natürlich
verlinkt wir waren richtig dass kurz
klar zu stellen also
mit dem erklärt und so nicht dass ich
irgendwie das der falsche eindruck
entsteht dass ich da das vertuschen
wollten okay leute ihr müsst nämlich
wissen ich hatte besuch vom fernsehen
genau genommen vom bdr und wir haben
eine wohnung hier besucht und mit
pflanzen ausgestattet das ist eigentlich
die ganze geschichte erklärt die nur
drei minuten deshalb hatte ich mal
zusammen mit euch reinschauen und
letzter im leben von student max spielt
sich viel rund um sein rotes sofa ab das
stimmt das spielt sich eigentlich alles
in dieser werkschau des roten immer alle
freude da wird schon immer auf der couch
sehr schön finde ich auch diese aufnahme
von meinen toren wo man sehen kann wie
viel mit 22 jährige ist als youtuber
ziemlich erfolgreich nur die farbe grün
die sucht man bei ihm vergebens noch
ehemann nummer eins ehrenmal nummer eins
es war wirklich cool war eine gute
erfahrung für den bdr zu drehen ich kann
euch das video auch nochmal verlinken ja
die sind einfach gekommen aber meine
wohnung mit pflanzen ausgestattet habe
mich davor gefragt ob ich bock drauf
habe und dann war ich person fern sind
sämtliche mit familienmitglieder die
mich als meine arbeit im internet noch
nicht werden mich jetzt haben also hast
du bist im fernsehen also getan als sei
das so vor der durchbruch wurde weil ich
schon seit ewigkeiten videos aber das
war wirklich absolut authentisch
gespräch ist nicht erst beim fünften
versuch so passiert
dank gehört hier fehlt noch was in der
wohnung und ihr müsst unbedingt
dranbleiben ich werde euch ein update
geben wie die pflanzen jetzt aussehen
guckt euch das an alter sie haben eine
komplette wohnung zurück bleiben die
pflanzen absolut also offensichtlich
habe ich um hilfe gebeten
also viele meiner freunde haben jetzt
kürzlich zimmerpflanzen geholt und das
ist einfach nur ein kleiner trend
deshalb wird es für mich jetzt auch mal
zeit nachzulegen aber auch vor
interessant wird heute so seht ihr einen
kleinen einblick in meine wohnung weil
ich habe natürlich schon an vielen orten
in meiner wohnung youtube videos gedreht
aber ich habe nie irgendwie so im
krassen überblick gezeigt und die haben
das schon ganz gut gemacht
klar ist ja in aller munde und
irgendwann gibt es durchaus ein paar
megatrend zu kennen das ist auf der
einen seite pflanzen die großen blättern
ja zum beispiel hier die banane auf mann
der überall überall in jedem garten
stand der bananenpflanzen richtig können
und ich musste sagen
rüdiger ramme also damit dass gerade mir
erklärt absoluten das faltblatt oder
elefanten ursachen auch dazu also
richtig riesige blätter ich dann hast du
da so manches klappt effekten der stelle
einfach hin sie einfach nur cool finden
reicht aber nicht auch max muss die
neuen mitbewohner künftig im blick
behalten
die spoiler ich habe die ganzen pflanzen
bekommen und die zwei wochen nämlich
gegossen das erste was sie mal war sie
nicht gießen wie oft muss ich die
pflanzen gießen also muss ich dem er und
die weniger wichtiger experte
na ja gerne sich ein profi für wohl also
ich hab nicht allzu viel substanz
imitiert zu ihr werdet sehen aber es war
auf jeden fall eine coole erfahrung und
die waren super lief also das kann man
so pauschal gar nichts sagt der tod der
meisten pflanzen ist zu viel wasser
okay nicht zu wenig wasser am besten ist
der test mal die franks rausheben ist
leichter nachweisen sollte doch selbst
als student zu schaffen sein und das
macht den original zimmer
das tier werde es jetzt mit den schemen
jetzt mittlerweile ein bisschen ihr für
die künstlich sie haben sie waren
niemals hier da sie nicht gesehen nicht
mehr in meine wohnung oder das war der
fernsehbeitrag nämlich zu gast war es
war eine coole erfahrung ich fahrzeugs
zeigen und gucken wir mal kurz zusammen
was es jetzt mit dem platzen so auf sich
hat okay leute das erste was ich sagen
muss hier ein paar pflanzen wieder
mitgenommen aber machen wir es kurz und
schmerzlos das so ist geht er sehr gut
zu sehen ist irgendwie ein bisschen
schief was macht man ihnen stiefel
pflanzen schreibe es in die kommentare
ja ich weiß auch nicht so recht
irgendwie richtig die sicherheit von
nachdem legt aber sich deutlich größer
geworden und ich glaube es geht hier
sehr gut diese hänge pflanze hier geht
es auch gut ist es nicht ein wunder
schon zwei pflanzen überlebt haben ja
die waren halt überall so und jetzt ist
er halt verbessert warum das so ist weiß
nicht es ist ja nach zu wenig licht in
der wohnung und hat auch ein bisschen
haarausfall die pflanzen die hier
naja ein bisschen dezimiert aber das
okay aus ansonsten naja die das
komplette schreiben aber erwarte ich
sage also ich würde sagen 50 prozent der
pflanzen die ich habe als kleines update
danke fürs zuschauen wir sehen uns
nächste video wieder was gut und bis
dahin tschüss